hi Matt Phil mysticism me home isn't
simply the place where you were born
home is also the country that gives you
the opportunity to achieve something
what's my vantage I always say I have
two homes it's you where I was born and
balloon where I now live - why - hi
IRA's and Erica Ruffalo run a Cuban
restaurant in Berlin la pequeña Havana
or Little Havana before they opened it
four years ago they did a lot of
research they discovered that while
there were several Cuban bars there was
no truly Cuban restaurant in the city so
it was high time to open one first
am i Stefan the body's really like about
Germans is that they're fearless when it
comes to trying out new kinds of cuisine
they're very flexible free and open to
new experiences and they're very honest
IRA's Garofalo grew up in a small town
in the West of Cuba she had her first
child at 17 in 1999 an uncle who lived
in Berlin invited her to come visit she
decided to stay at home she had been an
English teacher in Germany she started
to work in restaurants gastronomie film
I've always found gastronomy interesting
we don't have that in Cuban people
opening their own businesses although I
trained in another profession I've
always been drawn to the restaurant
strange yet well even as a little child
I would love to spend time in the
kitchen with my grandmother she would
always cook for lots of people and I was
there with her
Unni Schwab EMA soda by Erik Garofalo
was born in the same town as his wife
they live just fifty meters apart but
they never met back then
he studied agricultural science and then
left for Italy that's where he met eros
who was on holiday there Eric has lived
in Berlin for 10 years now he taught
himself how to cook and he is always
experimenting and dreaming up new
recipes Cuban cuisine is an enduring
source of inspiration it is itself a
fascinating mix of influences among them
African and Spanish your single bossy
important I am really passionate about
what I do I always enjoyed cooking and
learned a lot working in various
establishments I thought about it for a
long time and then I decided to do this
and present my culture and cook for the
German public
ropa vieja is the Cuban national dish
the name means old rags but the dish is
a beef stew the recipe calls for flank
steak because it shreds well when cooked
Cuban cuisine tends to be spicy and
highly seasoned with plenty of garlic
cumin and bay leaves bay leaves are also
pictured in the Cuban coat of arms
they're a symbol of strength
to make ropa vieja the meat is boiled
till tender and then it's pulled apart
and looks like old rags
[Music]
the history of the dish has long been
disputed some say it originated on the
Canary Islands others say it comes from
mainland Spain at the plateau Circle
machine it's something you can always
eat it makes a great family meal because
it's so practical in fact you can make
two horses with the one piece of meat
first a hearty soup with noodles and
then use the meat to make a delicious
warp of year the restaurant isn't sure
about a mainly residential neighborhood
with lots of Melos street life and cafes
people have come here to enjoy
themselves since the mid 19th century la
pequeña Habana is not on a main road
hordes of hungry people don't
necessarily come in just by chance the
start was difficult but its reputation
has been growing and many of its patrons
are regulars now I love the atmosphere
and the people recommend it it was very
tasty it feels like a piece of Cuba
that's where I'm from if you live abroad
it's important to have somewhere that
feels like home that's why we come here
there is the regular menu and various
specials but the dish that is in
greatest demand is rubber beer huh
Oh mo cocinando para ustedes la ropa
vieja un pleito muy querido en toda
Booga espero Lehi Utah dou y de cerdo
muy buen provecho